so i want to ask you about glo because
any word on season four
filming where you guys at we're uh
supposedly coming back 2021 there's just
no
there's no specific date but we have
gotten a word from netflix that
uh just with all the logistics of both
the pandemic and it being
a large-scale wrestling show with high
context
we are just going to defer for until
2021
and i'm really hopeful for the final
season
like i want us girls to to have that
closure sad news for glow fans it was
announced on monday that the gorgeous
ladies of wrestling will
not move forward with their fourth and
final season as a result of the
coronavirus pandemic
e.t chatted with actress sunita mani
about the possibility
just days before the announcement
netflix has kind of been like
okay like we're not doing the society
we're not doing all these other shows
and i'm like
you touch glow don't you touch blue
thanks for being on the lookout
i know i hope we come back it's such a
special
unique show and it's funny that it is
like
theater on film so that it is
unfortunately suffering during this
pandemic
do you have any hopes for for the final
season
i really want to see arthy have
like just a like a
badass um kind of ownership of her
identity like she's sort of going
through these phases and and really
finding herself
and it is comically
bad sometimes like i i i feel like she's
such a heartbreaking and heartwarming
character i love her so much
but uh i would love to have see her just
really own
herself the show i mean that [ __ ] has
really made it spark it's gonna be sad
to see it go
no it's such a special thing i have high
hopes for this final season it's gonna
be like
truly cathartic it's been like the joy
of all of our lives
so be sad to see that while glo will not
be getting the send off fans hoped for
you can catch sunita with the debut of
two of her films
evil eye and save yourselves is this
been near the wall
the poof i don't know probably oh my god
flip stuff it's like a heartwarming uh
misadventure
it's like an innocent apocalypse
compared to like what we're going
through now you know
i was gonna say so this movie couldn't
have come out at this more like
accurate time does the state of things
kind of
change your perspective of how you view
the movie now
a little bit it makes it feel even
sweeter and more surreal in a way
because fact of life is
is feeling more surreal than like an
alien invasion
um but i i felt like the movie was
quite timeless like reading the script
um
this relationship story kind of going
through the nitty-gritty of the end
at the end of the world is like it's
just such a funny great premise that
uh sort of takes phones out of the
equation so the look of it and the feel
of it is like
this isolated upstate cabin um
and i love that throwback quality of it
so it felt very timeless
when we were shooting it but now it is
ultimately so timely that it is
it's bizarre this couldn't come out
after
this pandemic i don't think and hit the
same way and it's in a way perfectly
timed
for us all to deeply relate and
hopefully escape into
it's it's wild because in august my
partner and i were like
let's go on a camping trip and unplug
and i did the same thing as where i was
like i feel like i
i gotta like check my phone the entire
time
it's it feels like so wild to do
what they did in this moment like
knowing what we know now about like
the state of the world and experiencing
so many
devastating things and and changes like
rapid changes in the new cycle
um yeah i agree i find myself being
uh sue like more and more
like being on the couch looking at my
phone like the parallels between myself
and the character are even stronger now
um and i like respect her choices
so much more than like my own i think
yeah i'm like
a more gross version of her and she's
quite capable
i don't want you to fall in love with
the wrong man why can't you just be
happy for me
i also want to talk about evil eye
because i just watched this as part of
the
blumhouse spooky season i loved your
story and it unravels in this like
really psychological way so
i'm curious what appealed to you most
about being a part of that story
i was drawn to
like the the sheer concept of it i
thought it was
quite smart to like bring in
the horror genre um to this
like to the story of reincarnation
i thought that was brilliant like i i
really appreciated that someone a south
indian writer was like fleshing out this
concept that i
grew up sort of familiar with like evil
eye as a concept so
i was really drawn to like the specific
uh culturally indian nature of it
and that it would feature um emerging
directors like first time directors and
uh
this like emerging writer and an indian
cast
specifically sarita chowdhury when i
knew she was on board that was like the
tipping point
for me of like oh well then i'm doing
this and so it was
yeah a huge cell to work with an actress
like her
it was so good and just like the
perspective of like the mom
like being overbearing and you're like
god mom and then you're like ish wait is
she
right or is she the one that's like just
being overbearing like it was just right
hold that line so well i i did i'm so
glad yeah because it takes these
sort of stereotypes you know they're
just like the tropes of the overberry
mother wants
her daughter to like get married and you
know
her charts are really important and
they're you know dictating her life and
it sort of
it sort of leans into it in an
interesting way that
is it's quite psychologically thrilling
and i enjoyed that this was backed by
executive produced by priyanka chopra
right
so yeah yeah that was another thing like
blumhouse amazon and priyanka chopra
jonas all elevating
this script and this idea and all of us
like
coming together to make this movie i it
was
it was sort of like an insane
combination of things that i
i like tiptoed into being like is this
real
is this real well i i feel like watching
you know
these two movies kind of within like
days of each other i was like
you're such a chameleon of an actress
like it's almost like i was i felt like
i was watching two completely different
people which is what it should be
because they're two different characters
but
do you have like a dream role that you
want to do is there something on your
bucket list you'd want to
tackle next i don't
know i feel like i'm just getting
started and i'm getting to
play such like larger than life
characters
like on glow and and then you know
playing like romantic leads like an evil
eye and then like this
doing this fun indie like that is the
dream to me like to get to do this range
of roles and i hope that i can
continue to be as fluid as possible
and just sort of like take the good
projects like i just like it's all about
the script
and sort of like yeah
these interesting ideas that i'm excited
to like flush out
but i can't i don't think there's
anything specific i'm just so happy to
like
be in this field working
it's it's like more than i could ask for
and i hope it keeps
flowing well you're absolutely killing
it so
thank you thanks so much lovely